[Music]
so
[Music]
so
[Music]
hello i'm zoe ha and i'm a fourth year
medical student in the uk currently i'm
off university and enjoying my summer
holidays but on the side to fund my
summer travels i work as an interpreter
slash translator i just logged on to the
mobile portal where i give translation
services for doctors nurses and even for
the ambulance by the way i translate
from turkish to english english to
turkish so i translate for turkish
patients i do live translation over the
phone and while i wait to receive calls
i'll be going on to anki to review my
flashcards so that i can refresh some of
my medical knowledge for the upcoming
university year so that i don't waste
time while i wait to receive calls and
i'm productive also at the end of the
day i'll let you guys know about how
much money i make today and how much
revision i got done as well
hello this is zeliha interpreter
turkish this call may be monitored for
training and quality assurance purposes
[Music]
[Music]
oh
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
i just had my dinner but now i'm bored
of working in my room so i'm going to
have a quick change of scenery but i'll
keep hustling for that new york and
turkey trip that i want to go on holiday
this summer also for my future self in
fourth year let's get this done
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
currently it's half past 11 which is
very late for me but i had a reasonably
productive day today i managed to hit my
daily target which is 150 pounds and i
earned 153 pounds and 56 pence which
means i worked over 10 hours because my
hourly rate is 1440. i also went through
a fair amount of flashcards in between
calls i actually learned what i was
translating to because in this job it's
like you're always on clinical
attachment because you translate the
conversations between consultants and
gps and their patients so it especially
improves my history taking skills and
also i hear about management of
different types of diseases i'm actually
very grateful for this job because i get
paid to do this but also it helps me in
my medical school exams too so thank you
so much for watching i hope you enjoyed
this if you did please consider
subscribing and liking this video and
also if you want to know more about this
job so how i applied and anything at all
if it's going to be helpful i'm more
than happy to do a video about it so let
me know and i'll see you in the next one
you